[Music]
Emma Stone back from the dead heck yeah
plus four other picks that will rise to
the occasion along with a black comedy
where stone is basically playing
Frankenstein's monster we've got an
anime fantasy flick Julia Roberts facing
an apocalypse the return and once again
the exit of the popular character Monk
and a psychological Thriller with Anne
Hathaway it's all coming up on this
week's what to watch sponsored by poor
things this is
Bella Bella this is Mr mandles hello
Bella first up and hitting theaters is
the black comedy poor things FYI the QR
code to get your tickets for this one is
up already that's how confident I am in
these three reasons to check it out
starting with that Stellar cast with
Emma Stone and William defo leading the
way it also features names like Mark
Ruffalo Ramy Yousef and Gerard carmichel
reason to is the fun and interesting
premise based on the 1992 novel of the
same name by Alice dere gray it follows
a young Victorian woman who is
resurrected by a scientist then she runs
off with a corrupt lawyer to really find
herself the third reason is that the
yorgos Lanos directed poor things is
already rich with praise from critics
after premiering at the Venice film
festival in September and earning the
festival's highest honor critics are
calling this very fresh film wildly
imaginative and exhilaratingly over the
top and a bizarre brilliant toward the
forest for its director and star now you
know why that QR code is so handy for
you dramatic pause moving on dear Mother
she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide also hitting theaters this week is
the Japanese animated fantasy film the
boy and the Heron reason one to immerse
yourself into this Fantastical world
complete with a talking gray Heron of
course is that it was written and
directed by the famous hayo Miyazaki a
co-founder of studio jibli and one of
the most accomplished filmmakers in the
history of of Animation you heard that
right and speaking of Studio jibli which
is behind the boy and the Heron it is
responsible for five of the 10 highest
grossing anime films in the history of
Japan including the Oscar winning film
Spirited Away they know what's up in
other words the third reason to give
this one a shot is the star studded
English-speaking voice cast that has
stepped into these roles for its release
over here that includes two batmen
Robert patson and Christian Bale Gemma
Chan Dave Bautista Florence Pew Mark
Hamill and list goes on
seriously I'm so sorry to bother you
that this is our
house this is your house arriving on
Netflix this week is the apocalyptic
Thriller Leave the World Behind and if
reason one to see this was only one word
it would be Julia but thankfully I can
expand a bit and by that I mean star and
producer Julia Roberts who's joined by
folks like Maha Ali Ethan Hawk and Kevin
Bacon another reason not to leave leave
the world behind behind trust me it
tracks is the creepy and intriguing
premise about a family in a luxurious
vacation home who is visited by two
Strangers in the Night with news of
impending doom and this looming disaster
gets more terrifying by the minute as
they all endure it together a third
reason is that the film was written and
directed by Sam esmail probably best
known as the creator of Mr Robot enough
said but just for good measure he also
worked on the Prime series homecoming
with wait for it Julia Roberts Adrien
monk for while there you were solving a
major case every week I couldn't have
done it alone I could have but it would
have taken longer landing on peacock
this week is Mr Monk's last case a monk
movie of course the first reason to tune
in to this one is that he's back Tony
shal's monk was last seen delighting
audiences on the USA Network back in
2009 some 14 years ago good Lord and
speaking of which another reason to
check out this movie is that the show
was a massive hit with an over overall
fresh Tomato Meter score in the low 9s
monk won eight emys over eight seasons
and set the record for the most watch
scripted drama episode on cable in 2009
until the Walking Dead surpassed it 3
years later gosh darn it Walking Dead
the third reason to get into Mr Monk's
last case is all the familiar faces in
front of the camera like of course
shaloo malora Harden Ted LaVine and
Hector elzando along with longtime show
director Randy zis who is also helming
the movie A Reunion good afternoon
e how's your day Dad it was the day just
another day my day was a doozy also
creeping in the theaters this week is
the psychological Thriller Eileen the
film stars Thomas and McKenzie along
with names like Anne Hathaway heard of
her and the always great Shay Wingham
they helped tell this story set in 1960s
Boston about an unhealthy friendship
between two women working at a juvenile
detention center there's reason one and
1A to try this one out reason too is
that it's based on the award-winning
debut novel of the same name by otessa
MOS who also adapted the screenplay with
her husband impressive and reason three
is that after premiering at Sundance
earlier this year it's already fresh on
the Tomato Meter with a critics
consensus that calls hathway and
McKenzie a well-matched duo we did it
five solid picks to keep your viewing
schedule fluid and don't forget you can
get your tickets literally right now to
poor things peep the QR code here to
make it easy and the future you will be
thanking the present you guaranteed oh
and one last thing before we fly out of
here we want to let you know that
tickets are officially on sale for the
upcoming animated Adventure comedy
migration and you know we've got a handy
QR code for you boom get them now be
entertained later it's so simple and
that's the kind of thing you can apply
elsewhere in life too like your next
meal at Jersey miks for instance Order
ahead be satisfied later even our boy
Uncle Dan approves and that's not always
[Music]
easy
remember to check out rot tomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large that
is all for today fresh family until next
week stay
fresh